[Music]
welcome everybody to our debate
capitalism and kovat I'm really looking
forward to it we've got three fantastic
speakers this pandemic has led to calls
for a radical overhaul of capitalism the
sight of governments spending hundreds
of billions of pounds or dollars or
euros on interventions has made ideas
like a universal basic income look more
plausible to many but is radical change
deliverable and would it work for the
benefit of all
should we see the global response to the
pandemic as evidence that massive
government intervention is the solution
to society's inequalities or is this
fantasy and that the huge interventions
will instead lead to a painful hangover
hard times for everyone and lest freedom
and dynamism in our societies we do have
three amazing a guest Paul Krugman is a
widely regarded as one of the most
important economists in the world he won
the Nobel Prize in 2008 he's a
distinguished professor at City
University of New York and an op-ed
columnist for The New York Times Deirdre
McCloskey is a distinguished professor
Meritor economics and of history at the
University of Illinois she's written 24
books some of which have been incredibly
influential they're all great but some
of which have been incredibly
influential in changing people's views
about economic history and development
and she's well known for her 2019 book
wide liberalism works grace Blakely is
an economic journalist for the New
Statesman in her first book stolen grace
argues that democratic socialism is
urgently needed to resolve mounting
inequality and the domination of
financial capitals so we're going to
start with this should we see the global
response to the pandemic as evidence
that massive government intervention is
the solution to society's inequalities
over to you Paul
okay so by the way I am in favor of
massive government intervention to
redress inequality but I don't think
that this pandemic tells us a whole lot
about that I mean if your if your view
is that a government can never be of any
use at all then you should be having a
reality check right now because
government action is clearly essential
right now but and the government in many
ways it is in fact a what we're trying
to do is address inequality primarily
the inequality if some people are in are
much more directly affected by the
pandemic than others and we're trying to
provide some compensation for that some
cushioning but that turns out to
interact with pre-existing inequality on
average the people who are losing a
livelihood or are lower paid than those
who are not but that it it's something
we did doing anyways but I think what we
need to understand is that although the
situation is unprecedented the role of
government here is actually pretty
traditional I think of this as an
festivals public health interventions
and we've been doing that since the 19th
century and second there's a it's
disaster release it's really and this
this is a long established role of
government we believe that the
government almost everybody believes the
government should step in when there's a
hurricane massive flooding a natural
disaster and that's basically what's
happening now as large numbers of people
are being hurt by a random disaster and
the government is stepping in to provide
aid so that it shouldn't really move
your views very much unless you were a
religious believer that government can
never do anything right it really
shouldn't move your views very much and
poll there are many people petition the
states who are seem to be suspicious of
the fact that the state has intervened
in this way in the same ways they were
suspicious when the state intervened in
the global financial crisis and they're
gonna want the state to get out of the
way as quickly as possible as the kind
of matter of ideological in necessity
yeah and that's where the if you had
that kind of ideological
blinders on
and this is your you should be having a
problem with this because if if you're
you know if you find the whole notion of
the government stepping in to help
people in need under any conditions
unacceptable then you are basically
saying let's let people starve or die in
the face of a pandemic and so you should
ask yourself of course if you're that
kind of person you probably not the kind
of person to ask yourself hard questions
anyway but if you if you if that's how
you're approached things looking at this
situation right now you should be asking
if my ideology is calling upon me to do
nothing and I'm calling upon the
government to do nothing in times like
this then maybe there's something wrong
with my ideology okay well I guess the
question we'll come back to later is
well what about after the crisis and the
role of the state in the economy then
but we'll come back to that in a moment
Paul because I want to bring in Deirdre
now so Paul rather disappointingly for
the organizers of this event if they're
expecting fireworks is basically so
there's not much to see here really this
is the state doing what you would expect
the states to do what what do you think
ever well I agree on the whole I agree
that if if Canada invades Maine as I'm I
can hardly sleep from the fear of the
dam the dam Canadians I think we should
I think the government the federal
government should leap forward and you
know draft people if necessary to fight
the Canadians not wait until they've
taken over all of the Northeast before
reacting and that's what the that's what
the that's what the governments of
Britain in the United States did they
waited until the the virus was very well
established by contrast many democratic
countries like South Korea and New
Zealand and Australia and of all
countries Greece I have had remarkably
few fatalities from this because they
did the the duty
of any kind of state you I have some
friends who are anarchists or actually
anarchists I'm not I'm a I'm a liberal
in the corrected international
definition of the term and if you're a
complete anarchist you are against any
kind of government action but I don't
think the I don't think the people you
mentioned in the United States are
coming out of an ideology I mean there
are a few academics of my acquaintance
who are Inachus but mostly these people
who are protesting the opening of the
lockdown and want to you know gather in
large groups without any face masks to
scream about it they're just doing a
kind of macho Act such as individual one
as I prefer to call them engages in and
it's just it's incoherent it's not
ideological so I don't think a true
liberals ideology as much of as much of
as much affected by all this true some
authoritarian governments like Vietnam
have done a good job put in quotation
marks but mainly the authoritarian
countries the Russian Federation in in
particular and maybe China we're doing
altogether sure whether China has done
the good job it brags about they've done
it because it involves coercion and of
course coercive governments are very
good at course but what's clear is that
an ethical commitment to adult behavior
which is the core of liberalism works
and that's what our that's what Boris
Johnson
individual one should have done but
didn't great thank you
grace what do you make of of how this
may impact on people's attitudes to
intervention yeah I mean I think guy is
interesting actually because it shows it
it brought to mind for me a quote from
from Lennon who said that we should
never confuse big caps and estates doing
a lot of state intervention for
socialist States because they are two
very very different things
I think when I looked at this question
and my initial response was you know no
I've already agree with Paul that had
the state not stepped in to do all the
things that it's been doing then
yeah the impact on those individuals and
society at large would have been much
much worse no I think you know the issue
that we have now is that we have this
false dichotomy between free marketeers
and status we need libertarians and
Social Democrats let's say well actually
you know from a Marxist the sexes
there's the view would be that
capitalism is a holistic system States
creating markets and they do so in the
interests of capital accumulation and at
the beginning of this crisis the problem
that we had was that you know
potentially especially after the kind of
twelve years of secular stagnation which
was associated with a global debt third
and three times the size of world GDP
particular vulnerabilities for example
the corporate sector in both the US and
the UK there are a lot of those
companies and individuals that
potentially were on the verge of
bankruptcy the domino effect that can
have when the rest of the financial
system would have potentially been huge
so the state stepped in again just as it
did after 2008 and to clean up the mess
effectively and I think we have to you
know we can say on the one hand that
that was necessary to prevent larger
harms from coming about but I think we
also have to think about firstly what
kind of capitalism was being saved and
secondly what are going to be the
long-term implications of these
continuous interventions to bail out a
broken system I think you know a lot of
the problems that we had prior to to the
coronavirus are only gonna worsen as
this as this crisis continues I mean in
particular we've had you know over the
last thirty years there's quite
significant increase in mark
concentration in a lot of different
industries and that was seeing this on
steroids you know this is crises are
always moments where the kind of
Schumpeterian forces of creative
destruction accelerate and you see small
businesses fail brought up by larger
businesses but this is happening in a
huge way today because of the massive
cash piles that been built up by some of
the largest monopolies that ever existed
in history and some of those big
companies tick the Amazon Netflix those
companies that are doing so well after
crisis anyway you know the big tech
monopolies now constitute well this was
you know a week ago the start so it
could have changed who knows but they
began to constitute 1/5 of the S&P 500
which is a staggering level of
concentration for those those big
companies you're also seeing is
alongside that kind of monopolization
and market concentration which obviously
is not good news for capitalism the
extension of this problem really of
moral hazard which is yes a kind of
libertarian term but it's true there was
created the financial crisis where
effectively central banks are saying to
investors to companies that perhaps
aren't even credit worthy don't worry
about it you're gonna have access to all
the little quiddity that you need
actually near the state is even
potentially stepping in and saying you
know what we're gonna support a junk
bond market we're gonna start buying up
all different kinds of equities all
different kind of bonds just to ensure
financial stability without really
thinking about whether or not they're
supporting a healthy economy I think you
know we're going to end up in a
situation where we basically have a kind
of aversion of state monopoly capitalism
which was a theory put forward by a
number of early Marxists he basically
said that we'll get to a point in the
history of capitalism when you have
effectively planning of the economy
going on it's just completely
undemocratic because it's taking place
in society as a small number of very
powerful politicians how central bankers
financial CEOs come together and
effectively have such significant
control over huge sections of the
economy but they're able to say this is
what's gonna happen this is what's not
gonna happen central banks are
effectively planning on the principle if
you were business before the crisis then
you're going to exist after the crisis
right is that rational do we not want to
use this moment to build a
stainable economy do you want to use
this moment if there is going to be
government intervention to say right in
whose interests is that intervention
taking place so broadly and answer to
the question I think there is this
question we have to we have to look at
acts in whose interests is the state
operating when it does these you know
big expansive interventions and is that
the way that we want to run the economy
or is there a better way to ensure
democratic accountability over these
processes that are kind of taking place
all around us well that was great great
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas